a few months ago I was joined here in my
backyard by dr. James grime and he was
planting a sunflower here in this pot it
was all part of a big national project
and I'll put some information in the
link under the video but now I'm pleased
to reveal the sunflower grown up no
thanks to me I have to say but we are
having a bit of a problem you see we've
been counting the seeds here in the head
it's all to do with Fibonacci numbers
I'm sure you've all heard it before and
we did one count and we came up with 34
spirals and that's a Fibonacci number
that's what we were expecting but when
we counted the other way we keep coming
up with 54 spirals and not 55 it should
be 55 because that's the Fibonacci
number it is really hard counting seeds
in the head of a flower and maybe we're
doing it wrong
so I'm actually asking some of you guys
to go and have a look and do a count for
us and see what you think I'm gonna put
a nice big detailed picture of that on
my blog and on Flickr and I'll put links
under the video so go and have a look do
a bit of a count and see what you think
is this not a Fibonacci sunflower or are
we just a bit rubbish at counting the
spirals get in touch see what you reckon